people have been making pornography for
a very long time it's been on the sides
of temples in India on Greek verses in
Roman bedrooms in German drawing rooms
but a decisive moment in its history
came in 1839 with the French artist
Louie de Gaulle's invention of the
photograph known at first as the
daguerreotype which transformed the
availability and realism of sexual
imagery it was not long before the new
technology was being put to use to
explore a variety of explicit scenarios
one of the earliest a series of lesbian
encounters was made in Paris in the
spring of 1844 a time the pictures were
extremely expensive in the early 1850s
one daguerreotype cost a week salary for
a French worker it would point to that
one observer has been cheaper to hire a
prostitute for the day than to buy an
image of her but prices eventually came
down and the trade grew exponentially by
1860 they were estimated to be 400 shops
selling pornographic photos in Paris
they were available in packs of five on
sale from an army of women who kept them
under their dresses at all the big train
stations heterosexual packs typically
contained a selection of nude poses some
cunnilingus some anal sex and some light
bondage looking at the images there can
be a basic surprise a symptom of a
egoistic sense of uniqueness that they
could truly have got up to this sort of
thing our ideas of the past are likely
to be so dominated by sorts of politics
warfare and the machination zuv
quarterly attired aristocrats it can
take a moment to remember that our
ancestors were of course far more than
this there was a lot of cunnilingus and
a good deal of anal in the year of the
Great Exhibition and the charge of the
Light Brigade history teachers are
always attempting to bring the past to
life they try in a quest for a more
intimate sort of history to show us what
houses looked like and what an evening
meal might have consisted of they know
how much top hats can inhibit our powers
of empathy but there is no quicker way
to bring the 19th century vividly to our
imagination no more efficient bridge
across centuries than to be confronted
by tangi
evidence that they were in their deepest
cells despite all the Gulf's in ideology
and manners substantially just like us
in our more explicit and most animate
moments we may even start to look at
other centuries and times with newfound
empathy beneath the forbidding exterior
of the 16th century Doge Andrea gritti
painted by Titian was someone who might
have shared the gamut of our interests
we may have to rely on alessio
baldovinetti portrait for an idea of a
15th century Florentine lady but
empowered by the lessons of 19th century
porn we can guess that things would not
really have been so formal and so
otherworldly are peculiar and extreme
sexual imaginations with all the
complications and joy they give us have
been thrumming within our species
long before youporn we can feel at once
connected up to our ancestors and less
frightened of having lost our innocence
at the hands of our new technologies
there's something else about photography
with particular implications for
pornography photography is genius lies
in its ability to offer us a sense of
what feels like the present it is a
frozen moment of time rescued from the
dissolving force of the years but this
is also what makes photography
especially poignant when it's viewed
across decades or centuries we sense
with particular clarity the vivacity and
immediacy of people in all photos
against which the one irrevocable fact
we have in mind that they've all died
then stands out with touching starkness
their photographic liveliness makes
their eventual deaths all the more
tangible here are two people chatting in
a street in London in the 1870s for a
moment they live again and then they and
everything about their world is washed
away in the river of time as far as the
eye can see there are people stretched
out on a Coney Island beach in the 1920s
fit beautiful energetic with plans for
dinner a sense of fun worries and
intrigues every one of them swept into
oblivion by the tsunami of history the
poignancy is even more acute around
photographs of
children they have as they gaze at us so
much of a future ahead of them
and yet already it has gone everything
they were was eventually reduced to
nothing without knowing quite how it
could happen we never do they grew
married became little old ladies and
were laid out in their coffins one day
all these feelings stand to be
heightened with porn because having sex
is the ultimate activity of the moment
when we stand to forget time and lose
ourselves in the present absorbed by
everything that is contrary to the
implacable eternal the figures in the
porn of the 19th century are our
contemporaries they're no different from
us sucking thrusting defiling lost in
the emotions of now and we will
eventually go just the way they went
yet there is in porn also a heroic and
redemptive defiance of the grim future
in their moment of pleasure the figures
are denying what's going to happen they
don't right now care that they will grow
old and die and perhaps they are
inviting us not to either we can watch
them holding onto their pleasures and
simultaneously hold onto our own with
newfound gratitude these people weren't
ordered by their negligible place in the
implacable movement of the centuries
they had a penis to suck a vagina to
explore some stockings to put on and for
a time wisely knew how to forget the
upcoming apocalypse
you